[Music]
I'm not making this up
Pizza Hut has a new perfume and
supposedly it smells like a freshly
opened box of Pizza Hut Pizza yes
all true it's called Pizza Hut perfume
and Pizza Hut Canada gave away 100
bottles of it on Facebook but yeah well
guess what Conan I was one of the lucky
winners you won yeah this is this is
some of it right here I mean my god
that's treatable we'll try some right
now yeah yeah try it out okay what's it
smell like it's not bad it really does
smell like pizza but you're gonna okay
thank you you're gonna walk around
smelling like pizza for the rest of the
day you're okay with it I kind of like
it it's not so bad
hey guess what I kind of like it too
[Music]
and why don't you not get out of here
okay he's he's he's not going anywhere
he's got a show to do yeah you stay out
of this breadstick I know I hop the
truck slice a pizza when I smell one
come on
no thanks but I stuff your crust no
thank you
you can eat my sausage and meatballs hey
and then I'll show you my penis Oh
[Applause]
come on come on let's go back to my
place it's a pizza box I've got seven
roommates and fYI were always touching
tips sorry I'm sorry
get out of here right now get out yeah
please just leave me alone
I'm not Pizza sure you are your pizza
and we're gonna have sex get out get out
fine fine fine you come in Andy yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you